de momento se conocen pocos detalles más
sobre este misil el Estado Mayor
conjunto surcoreano ha informado tca
lanzado desde las de pyongyang y ha
dicho que se trata efectivamente de un
misil al menos de Rango medio o superior
de un misil balístico que ha sido
lanzado en dirección al mar de Japón
pocos minutos después de este
lanzamiento las autoridades japonesas
han activado la alerta en la isla
septentrional de hojaillo está alerta ha
instado a las personas a buscar Refugio
ha obligado a suspender los servicios de
tren ante la posibilidad de que cayera
pues o bien en la isla o en aguas
cercanas a la misma minutos después las
autoridades japonesas han desactivado
esta alarma al descartar esa posibilidad
y entonces la guardia costera nipona ha
indicado que el misil habría caído ya en
aguas digamos fuera de la isla de
hokaido pero todavía se desconoce
Incluso el punto Exacto donde habría
caído lo que sí se sabe es que el misil
podría haber volado en torno a una hora
hay un precedente en el pasado octubre
Corea del Norte lanzó un misil de Rango
medio que también sobrevolójo caído y
recorrió cuatro mil quinientos
kilómetros es la distancia récord de un
misil en norcoreano pero En esa ocasión
voló en torno a 22 minutos
Andrés de las dos coreas venían sin
mantener comunicación en los últimos
días algo inusual incluso para esos dos
países en qué momento se encuentran
estas donaciones
sí efectivamente Corea del Norte lleva
sin contestar a las llamadas que ha
realizado Corea del Sur en los últimos
siete días desde el pasado viernes el
Ministerio de unificación surcoreano que
es el responsable de las relaciones con
Corea del Norte ha indicado que cree que
se trata de una decisión unilateral por
parte de Corea del Norte es decir
descarta que se trate de un problema
técnico como ha sucedido en otras
ocasiones pues por ejemplo cuando llueve
mucho a veces las comunicaciones en
Corea del Norte han resultado dañadas en
este caso según cree que se trata de un
deseo norcoreano de romper en este
sentido las comunicaciones Aparentemente
sería en protesta por las maniobras
militares que tanto Corea del Sur como
Estados Unidos y en ocasiones Japón que
también se ha unido estos días a las
maniobras militares que están realizando
en el sur de la Península cabe pensar
también que Corea del Norte podría estar
mandando un mensaje
más grande porque el domingo arranca la
reunión de ministros de exteriores del
g7 que se celebra Precisamente en Japón